[Music]
the trailer for Jordan Peele us has just
dropped and other than having the best
use of Lunas --is I got five on it
there's a lot to unpack throughout this
video I'll be breaking down the major
things you may have missed as well as
the plot details that the teaser for the
film gives us there may be some spoilers
here so if you don't want to know
anything going into the film and I
highly suggest that you turn off now but
for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to okay so the first thing to take
from the trailer is that unlike peels
classic get out the movie is actually
not about race in a recent interview
with Collider appeals stated that it's
about something I feel has become an
undeniable truth and that is the simple
fact that we are our own worst enemies
this is a pretty clear motif in the
movie as we see a family being stalked
by what appears to be exact
doppelgangers of them this of course
ties into the title us and it's clear
that the replicas will be terrorizing
the family throughout the film the
trailer opens with the family driving to
their beach house for some R&R before
the Sun notices a blood-soaked figure
holding scissors on the beach the boy is
drawn towards him and then we cut to the
same night where dark and ominous
figures hover around their home before
attacking them judging by the marketing
material and figures themselves it's
clear that scissors will make a large
appearance throughout the film
could this be symbolism of self-harm as
scissors are often used in those kind of
circumstances the masks could also
potentially represent the masks that we
put on in social circumstances to appear
a certain way and it's clear that the
movie will delve into the more surreal
when we see bunnies hopping around a
hallway either way I can't wait to see
what the film has in store and if
there's anything that I missed or that
you took from the trailer be sure to let
me know in the comments if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and check
out my breakdown of the leaked
information that we have on the new Star
Wars Episode nine trailer which will be
linked at the end this is a channel for
people who are heavy into horror so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this and I just want to
wish everyone a Merry Christmas and a
happy new
I've watched the channel grow so much in
the last year and I couldn't have done
it without you - thank you and I wish
you all the best for 2018 take care
peace
[Music]